sie haben gestern im Angesicht des
Wahlsiegs in Hannover noch mal von der
Gefahr eines Dritten Weltkrieges
gesprochen wieso wollen sie den Leuten
Angst einjagen also ich meine wenn wir
die aktuelle Situation sehen auch heute
die Angriffe auf Kiew dann muss man sich
nur anschauen was aktuell in die in
Europa passiert was gerade in der
Ukraine in Russland passiert also nicht
ich mache Angst ich mache mir Sorgen um
Europa und ich mache mir natürlich auch
sie Sorge das ist ein dritten Weltkrieg
geben kann ja gut sie sagen es kann
einen geben aber wer will diesen dritten
Weltkrieg der Westen will nicht Putin
trotz seiner Drohungen auch nicht das
wird ja eine völlig verwüstete Erde
hinterlassen wieso übernehmen Sie dieses
framing von Wladimir Putin ich übernehme
keinen framing von Wladimir Putin wenn
ich alleine sehe was Residenz gehe auch
für Äußerungen schon getätigt hat dass
ihr hier einen atoman erzschlag fordert
da sehe ich dass die Eskalationsstufe
sich immer weiter dreht dass die
Eskalation Spirale sich immer weiter
dreht und dass wir endlich deeskalieren
müssen auch der Westen muss ich fragen
ob die Lieferung weiterer schwerer
Waffen zur deesk beiträgt und das sagen
wir ganz klar ist AFD nein
sie fordern die sofortige Aufhebung
aller Sanktionen abgesehen davon ob das
überhaupt politisch durchsetzbar ist
damit würde man ja aber die
Kriegsverbrechen in Butcher und in
istium sozusagen nachträglich noch
belohnen wissen Sie wir müssen mal
einiges unterscheiden was die
Kriegsverbrechen angeht was der
wirtschaftliche Schaden angeht und der
Wirtschaftskrieg den die Bundesregierung
hauptsächlich habe gegen Russland ja
hauptsächlich führt er schadet uns er
schadet Deutschland mehr als Russland
das sagt nicht nur die AFD aber das
Sagen mittlerweile
mehrere Verbände auch das info-institut
sieht das so und wir brauchen uns ja
bloß mal die wirtschaftlichen Daten
anschauen wer soll denn diesen Krieg wer
soll denn diese Situation eigentlich
noch bezahlen der Mittelstand das
Handwerk steht vor dem Kollaps immer
mehr Firmen machen Pleite da fragt sich
wie soll eigentlich das soziale Gefüge
in diesem Land noch zusammengehalten
werden also hier muss es beschleunigt
eine Änderung auch in dieser
Außenpolitik geben das heißt aber eine
Aufhebung der Sanktionen werden die
Kapitulation vor Putin nein man sollte
natürlich zuallererst ein waffenst
fordern und auch von Versuchen auf
diplomatischen Weg endlich hier an den
verhandlungstischen mit den drei
Parteien zu kommen mit der Ukraine mit
Russland natürlich und natürlich auch
mit der USA und dann kann man natürlich
diese Forderung stellen und dann kann
natürlich auch hat man auch was in der
Hand dass man sagt man kann Sanktion
lösen wenn es zum Beispiel zu einem
Waffenstillstand kommt also man muss
dich doch endlich mal in eine
friedensdebatte bewegen ich vermisse die
in jeder Weise und auch die
Bundesregierung dreht hier mit in Form
von einem von von weiteren Forderungen
was Waffenlieferungen angeht immer
weiter an der Eskalationsspirale zurück
zur möglichen Krise die uns bevorsteht
wenn die jetzt etwas glimpflicher
verläuft als befürchte das ist ja auch
allen zu wünschen das wäre schlecht für
die AFD denn sie haben ja etwa 50% ihrer
Wähler sind Protestwähler die werden
dann wieder weg wissen Sie wenn die
Krise schlimmer ist und nicht schlimmer
ist ich sehe aktuell was passiert ich
sehe dass der Gaspreis sich von neuen
fragt hat dass die Strompreise
kollabieren dass wir nicht wissen ob wir
über diesen Winter kommen Herr habe
gesagt wir müssen Glück haben also wenn
das ein Wirtschaftsminister sagt Dir
völlig inkompetent und überfordert zu
sein scheint dann wird mir wirklich übel
weil wir haben die viertgrößte
Industrienation ist Deutschland und wir
sehen aktuell was hier in diesem Land
passiert was macht mir Sorge und da hat
die AFD die richtigen Antworten gegeben
wir haben die Ursachen in diesem
Wahlkampf benannt und das sind die
Wirtschaftssanktionen die uns mehr
Schaden ja gut die wirtschaftssektion
die durch allerdings hier nicht einfach
so erhoben worden sind oder in gegen
Pudding gerichtet worden sind sondern
weil er die Ukraine überfallen hat also
diese Wirtschaftssanktionen haben ja
nicht den Sinn die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft ursächlich zu schädigen
sondern sie sind ein Mittel gegen Putin
ja aber das Mittel funktioniert ja nicht
das sehen wir aktuell es wird weiter
eskaliert der Krieg ist nicht beendet
und was wir aktuell auch erleben was
unsere Wirtschaft angeht das kann uns ja
nicht zufriedenstellen also wir zahlen
hier einen teuren Preis es ist nicht
unser Krieg also uns Deutschland hat
niemand den Krieg erklärt oder bin ich
der falsche informiert ja aber die
Ukraine
ist Völker zuwidrig angegriffen jeder
Krieg ist völkerrechtswidrig also es
gibt kaum Kriege nicht
völkerrechtswidrig sind und wir müssen
uns überlegen wie wir aus diesen Dilemma
herauskommen Deutschland hat sich sehr
schnell auf eine Seite gestellt das kann
man so oder so betrachten aber wir
müssen jetzt mal weiter denken wer soll
denn eigentlich der Vermittler sein in
diesem Konflikt das bleibt ja fast nur
noch die Türkei überhaupt wir müssen
noch endlich mal dahin kommen diesen
Konflikt versuchen mit
friedensdeformativ mit Verhandlungen zu
lösen ich sehe da keine Ansätze gut
die Deutschland steht auf der Seite der
Ukraine weil das Land angegriffen worden
ist völkerrechtswidlich angegriffen
worden ist noch mal ganz kurz zur AFD
und ihre weitere Zukunft hier in
Deutschland wie wird das eigentlich
jetzt aussehen die
wenn es in der wir haben so ein
Baden-Württemberg und Rheinland-Pfalz
2016 gesehen die flüchtlingskrise hat
der AFD sehr geholfen mit dem sehr guten
Wahlergebnis fünf Jahre später war es
damit wieder vorbei befürchten sie das
jetzt auch wieder ich denke wir haben
ein ganz anderen Kurs eingeschlagen wir
sind wesentlich geschlossener auch seit
Neuwahl des Bundesvorstandes auch das
nehmen Michael Lava die rechnen uns auch
wesentlich mehr kompetent zu wenn ich
alleine die Wählerwanderung jetzt auch
in Niedersachsen sehe 40.000 Wähler von
der FDP 45.000 von der CDU Protestwähler
ist doch wunderbar
wollen Sie jetzt den Protest Wählern
keine Kompetenz zu rechnen lassen also
Entschuldigung
die andere die anderen die andere Hälfte
wählt sie aus Überzeugung ja ist es in
lieber dass die Prozesse da gar nicht
Wähler wählen gehen dann haben wir eine
Wahlbeteiligung unter 60%. also mir ist
es lieb dass die Nichtwähler wählen
gehen natürlich sind Protest wäre dabei
das ist doch die Aufgabe einer
Opposition das ist Demokratie weil diese
Wähler halten wollen werden die Wähler
abgeholt das ist richtig weil wir auf
die richtigen Themen gesetzt haben und
weil wir vor allen Dingen die einzige
Partei sind die die Interessen
Deutschlands vertreten
wenn sie jetzt was oder was fangen Sie
mit diesem Wahlerfolg von 10,9%
eigentlich an
niemand will mit ihm koalieren ja ich
denke es ist erstmal ein richtiger und
wichtiger Schritt gerade in
Niedersachsen
wir jetzt nachdem auch die FDP Gott sei
Dank auch aus diesem Parlament
rausgeflogen ist das ist dort in der
Interessen geleitete Politik gibt dass
wir der Regierung auf die Finger schauen
wir werden sehen es wird dort
wahrscheinlich zu Rot-Grün kommen also
schlimmer hätte es eigentlich was
Regierungsbildung angeht für
Niedersachsen nicht kommen können und
wir werden natürlich auch für das
klientiert was uns gewählt hat Politik
machen für den Mittelstand für das
Handwerk für die Bürger die Arbeiten
gehen aber sie brauchen Bündnispartner
und die haben selbst die potenziellen
haben sie sozusagen in eine Art
paria-status versetzt ja was nützt ja
den denjenigen auch nichts also der
Zusammenschluss des gegenpolster AFD
zeigt er immer mehr dass diese Parteien
sich in keinster Weise mehr
unterscheiden deswegen ist im übrigen
auch die FDP rausgeflogen deswegen ist
auch die Bundesregierung genau in diesem
Dilemma also wer unsere Programmatik
unsere Politik sie anschaut wir stehen
immer bereit zu Gesprächen mit uns kann
man konservativ bürgerliche Werte
geleitete nicht Werte geleitete Politik
machen sondern interessengeleitete
Politik das ist unser Ansatz das ist die
Politik der AFD
der Bundessprecher der Partei bedanke
mich für das Gespräch